[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je v dans son blan et majecieux une
mouette arrivée du Grand Large elle
s'est posée sur l'eau près de la plage à
côté des rochers un peu après en vain
elle a essayé de repartir en s'agitant
désespérément alors je suis allée la
ramasser ses plumes étaient noires
toutes collées par le
mazout parfois le vent léger faisait
bouger son
[Musique]
aile je la tenais serrée serrit tout
contre
moi tâchant de retenir la vie qui
partait
d'elle d'alléger sa souffrance et calmer
son
effroi j'ai versé je l'avoue dans la mer
une
larme mais qu'est-ce dans les flots que
le bleu d'un
sanglot quand gluant l'écume et qu'en
noir sont les lames
couverte du pétrole des soutes d'un
cargo pauvre mouette toi qui
croyais près de la terre te
reposer il paraît qu'autrefois tous les
grands
[Musique]
capitaines sen aller droit au vent au
fond des
océans mais sont-ils des marins tous
ceux-là qui s'en
viennent pour faire mourir la mer et ce
qui est
dedans de ces yeux étonnés de souffrir
mais sans
haine l'oiseau me regardait et ne
comprenait
pas moi je tournais la tête et de honte
et de
peine en sentend dans mes mains son cœur
devenir froid
parfois le vent léger faisait bouger son
aile je la tenais serrée serrée tout
contre
moi tâchant de retenir la vie qui partit
d'elle en sentend dans mes mains son
cœur
devenir
froid
foreign